palestinian president mahmoud abbas says
palestine will not be bound by
agreements with israel and the u.s
because of israel's planned annexation
of 30 percent of the occupied west bank
addressing an emergency meeting of his
cabinet abbas described the u.s as
israel's partner in crime and he called
for countries that have rejected
president
donald trump's middle east peace plan to
recognize the state of palestine and
impose sanctions on israel
under trump's deal israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu could begin
annexing palestinian land as soon as
july
[Music]
the palestine liberation organization
and the state of palestine are not bound
to
as of today all the agreements and
understandings with the american and
israeli governments
and of all the obligations based on
these understandings and agreements
including the security ones
need ibrahim has the latest from
ramallah
while he said that the plo is no longer
bound by agreement signed
with israel he said that he did not say
that he's dissolving the palestinian
authority and
the palestinian authority itself is the
fruit of
the agreements that has been signed
between israel and the palestinian
authority in 1993 so we need a couple of
days or maybe weeks to understand what
really
is going to be taken on the grounds in
on the ground in terms of measures
by the palestinian authority now to the
issue of the security agreement between
the two parties
it has been suspended a couple of times
before
but in recent history we're talking
about the past 20 years this suspension
was only limited to the high profile
high-level meetings between the
palestinians
and israeli security officials but side
channels
have happened in the past between
palestinians and israelis that
kind of allowed this security
coordination to continue of course it's
very important
for the palestinians palestinian
authorities viability and many officials
here in the occupied west bank argue
that the palestinian authority's
establishment is an accomplishment
and that they are not looking at
just dissolving the palestinian
authority
arya bonimar is the co-founder of
electronic intifada
and the author of the battle for justice
in palestine he says the announcement by
abbas
is meaningless well there's two
important points here one is that
the creation of the palestinian
authority
uh was allowed by israel after 1993 for
one purpose
and one purpose alone which was to
create a
native palestinian auxiliary to
uh basically implement the occupation on
behalf of
israel and that is and has been the role
of the palestinian authority since its
creation
israel allows palestinian security
forces to have
guns but those guns are only to be used
against palestinians
and so the agreements are basically that
the palestinian authority
acts as a an auxiliary police force
for israeli occupation forces now
that's given the title security
coordination that's
the polite name for it that's given in
the agreement
the head of the pa has announced i i
can't remember how many times uh
that he's suspending this agreement or
that agreement
and the fact is he's never done that
he's never suspended an agreement and
indeed this evening
as we're speaking palestinian authority
sources told the israeli newspaper
that in fact a security collaboration
between
the israeli occupation forces and the
palestinian authority
is continuing and will continue and the
reality is that the palestinian
authority
can't move assault shaker from one side
of a table to another
without the permission and help of the
israeli occupations